the number of virus cases in Russia has
been soaring this month Russia reported
far fewer infections at many Western
European countries in the early stages
but on Sunday the Russian Crisis
Response Center reported a record rise
of 6,000 60 new cases from a day earlier
that brings its nationwide total to
nearly 43,000 Micaiah Larry omen has
been very busy since the corona virus
pandemic hit the 23 year old student is
in charge of public relations at the
Church of Saint Tatyana in Moscow since
early April
he's been streaming the services here
online after the Russian Orthodox Church
called on people to start praying at
home when Yulia is college they called
me from the church and said we have to
go online and the first thing I thought
was I don't know anything about how to
do this but now the live streams have
become crucial this Palm Sunday was the
last Easter service worshippers in
Moscow could attend in person
[Music]
even though far fewer people were going
to church than usual Moscow authorities
decided Easter services were too risky
during the pandemic and issued an order
to the church to close their doors to
worshipers to father Vladimir and his
congregation having to let go of Easter
traditions is a heavy burden to bear
[Music]
it's got a blue problem I am mourning
the fact that people have been driven
out as the church it doesn't matter what
the circumstances are as they've been
driven away a few days later and these
empty spaces have become the new normal
for churches in Moscow this church may
have to stay empty for a while now but
right now hundreds of people are
watching this service live on YouTube
[Music]
Macario min thinks that people will come
back to church after quarantine measures
in Moscow and but he also believes in
his live streams many churches have
started streaming and that means they're
also telling more people about Orthodox
Christianity of course the ideal
scenario is that people will come to our
church later after watching our live
streams the authorities in Moscow say
they may extend the measure after Easter
Sunday but in most other regions of
Russia churches will stay open to
worshipers for Easter and Emily Sherwin
is standing by for us in Moscow with the
latest Emily hello to you it's an
alarming increase in the numbers of
infections being seen in Russia what is
happening where you are it really is an
alarming rise in cases in the last five
days the cases have actually doubled
here in Russia on the one hand that may
just be because case numbers and numbers
of infections are rising as the virus
spreads through the country but the
official line here and
I think a very logical explanation as
well is that they have just stepped up
testing in the past weeks very
significantly for example there are more
labs now and apparently nearly two
million tests have been carried out and
with over a hundred thousand tests being
carried out just in the last 24 hours so
really a huge number there of tests
happening and that now includes people
who don't have symptoms people who are
likely to have been infected like
medical war prett workers or people who
have had contact with someone who's
infected and officials here in moscow
where most of the cases more than half
of the cases have been found have been
saying that actually around 60% of
people in the capital here could be
carriers without having any symptoms so
that strategy of testing certainly makes
sense
all right so authorities reacting with
ramped up testing but Emily how are
normal people responding to this
situation how worried are they and do
they trust the authorities are doing the
right thing well I think people are
worried here people on the other hand
you know have been told to stay home
rather strict measures that have been
happening here for the past few weeks
even before this huge number of cases
people have been told especially in the
capital but also in most other regions
across Russia to stay home just and just
leave the house to go to the supermarket
or to walk their dog within a hundred
metres of their homes so really strict
self-isolation measures and of course
Russia isn't yet at it's at the peak of
infections so that's pretty difficult
for people here in Russia and in Moscow
especially where there have been most of
the cases as I said they've even
introduced a system of electronic passes
so people who want to leave their houses
and take a public transportation or take
car journeys have to sign up every time
on a government website
that is a measure of course to stop
infection spreading but it is tough on
people alright DW is Emily Sherman
reporting for us from Moscow we thank
you very much